[Music]
tech companies do way more than tech
these days
they're now an indispensable part of our
everyday lives
from how we communicate to how we shop
and pay for things
many have grown quickly in less than two
decades and that's especially true in
china
alibaba is the biggest e-commerce
company in the country
by most measures and runs a system
called alipay which is this
phenomenally important payment platform
last year more than 700 million people
used alibaba's platforms to buy things
online
and more than a billion people use the
fintech giant ant group's mobile app
to make payments borrow money buy
insurance and invest
we just depress buy alibaba was founded
by chinese entrepreneur jack ma
and he's ant's controlling shareholder
the two companies helped steer the
country into the digital marketplace
and pushed it to become an increasingly
cashless society
their impact on the economy has drawn
the attention of chinese regulators who
like their counterparts in the u.s
have been trying to rein in big tech
there isn't much really that governments
in washington and beijing can all agree
on
but at the moment push is underway to
curb the power
of the world's biggest tech giants china
appears to be moving on a faster time
frame for much of this than the us
here's how china was able to bring jack
moss companies in line
in just a few months the main driver of
why china can move fast is because of
its political system
china is a highly centralized one-party
state
and so that means in turn that when the
chinese authorities do
decide to do something they can
sometimes move much faster
and that type of speed when it comes to
regulatory action was on full display
with alibaba and ant
it all started with this speech by jack
ma in october of last year
in this speech jack mark effectively
criticized the people who are
responsible for overseeing the chinese
economy and for overseeing his
companies
and as the wall street journal has
reported that
infuriated china's top leaders and in
fact
president xi jinping himself made the
decision
my colleagues have reported to scupper
the pending
ipo event as a result partly of
the speech ant was supposed to list on
thursday
and not anymore what would have been the
world's largest ipo
was called off less than two weeks after
that speech that kind of direct
intervention by a national level
leader in what is effectively a kind of
commercial process
it's not like you would necessarily see
something equivalent happening
in the u.s about two months later
chinese regulators came down hard on
moz2 companies
they criticized ant's behavior toward
consumers and rivals
and told it to refocus on its payments
business and fix problems in newer
ventures
regulators also launched an anti-trust
investigation into alibaba
saying the company abused its dominant
market position forcing some sellers to
operate only on its platforms
alibaba didn't comment on the
allegations while ann said it
appreciated the guidance
that probe lasted less than four months
and alibaba was hit with a 2.8 billion
dollar antitrust fine
while ant will soon be directly overseen
by china's central bank
so for mos speech to penalties
regulators made it all happen
in under six months in the us you might
expect some of these things to last
many years just take a look at four
american big tech giants that have been
accused of anti-competitive behavior in
the digital marketplace
the testimony you're out to give is true
and correct to the best of your
knowledge
information and belief so help you god
while the usually visible jack ma
disappeared after the ipo was scrapped
in the u.s the ceos were called to a
very public hearing in front of house
lawmakers
you had four of the most powerful
technology executives in the world
subject to hours of hostile questioning
which came from both sides of the aisle
this hearing came amid a congressional
fact-finding investigation
that had been underway for more than a
year remember chinese regulators
anti-trust investigation into alibaba
from start to finish
took about four months at the end of the
house democrats 16-month probe
lawmakers concluded that the four
companies had leveraged their dominance
to stamp out competition
and stifle innovation republicans said
they supported strong antitrust
enforcement targeting the companies
the four companies disputed the findings
since then there have been a series of
blockbuster lawsuits launched by u.s
federal agencies and state governments
aimed at enforcing existing antitrust
rules but as
of april u.s regulators and lawmakers
haven't ordered these companies to
reform their business practices
the u.s is of course a democracy with
all of the checks and balances
and requirements for transparency that
that involves
and that means that companies can push
back for example the popular
chinese-owned video sharing app
tick-tock we're looking at tick-tock we
may be banning tick-tock
in august last year the trump
administration signed an executive order
that could effectively ban americans
from using and downloading the app
this was over concerns that user data
could be shared with the chinese
government
ticktock said that the chinese
government has never asked for user data
and would refuse such a request within
the u.s legal system the company
fought back tiktok filed lawsuits
against the order and less than two
months later
a federal judge blocked the
administration's van but for jack ma and
his companies
there was no room for appeal chinese
political context basically it makes it
much harder for companies
or others to push back if they disagree
alibaba immediately accepted the fine
and said it would invest in measures to
support merchants on its platforms
while ann said it would maintain the
continuity and quality of its services
while it fully complies with regulations
this regulatory assault has also gone
beyond jack moss companies
a few days later nearly three dozen
other big tech companies in china also
vowed to comply with the country's
anti-monopoly regulations
so while these two companies have been
shining examples of chinese innovation
from beijing's perspective their success
needs to align with the party's
interests
if there was a sense in which it was
allowing the private sector to
command bits of the economy it is now
kind of pushing alibaba and other
companies to fall
more tightly in line with its own
priorities
it's about kind of making sure that
government control or
party control over the chinese economy
is secure